had Shady Goliath records um how can I
get in contact with easy move but it's
like kind of like nah that can't be
realistic
um I had to be our people at virgins and
kind of give us a shrug like hey yo this
for real there's a serious meeting
that's gonna happen
um so you're gonna be meeting Eminem
they comboed me with like when I got
back to the And Dre's gonna be there too
like
I was so nervous like Dre was sitting on
the couch like kind of in a Lobby like
that and he stood up when I went in like
hey Superstar what
said to me you what you're Dr Dre so and
then I kept walking went to like the
angel to see in the door and I saw him
sitting at the edge while I like spinned
again like in disbelief and then he
stood up when I walked to the door to
the studio he was like Ezekiel
you've been the last 20 years
oh right you were four